Garrison's lovely to see you again here
at fright first tell us about your
segments safe haven in VHS - okay so
safe haven is basically what would
happen if team of journalists went into
the Jonestown group on the day of the
massacre so it's basically like you know
that idea of when the ship is about to
all fall apart and all come down like
what would you do in our situation and
to kind of like throw a journalist team
in today yielded pretty interesting
results for us but I gotta say like I've
been saying this a couple times already
but the the real [ __ ] brainchild of
the story was team on my coder act like
he came up with the whole idea of the
concept for it and I was just throwing
the cameras around which I said did a
great job now how would you cope do you
think if you'd been in the situation
those journalists found themselves a
nerd the short film if I was in that
situation I wouldn't have [ __ ] gone
in there in the first place we did
someone really did some research in
pre-production by Timo played me the
audio of like the actual Jonestown
Massacre like the day of it when he was
given the instructions to all the people
to drink the kool-aid and honestly it
was the most terrifying thing I've ever
heard I could give me the creeps and it
freaked me out and so basically I was
very much like you're thinking okay well
this is very like dark aggressive stuff
how are we gonna actually do this in a
short film because otherwise it's like
the chauffeur would be just about pain
and suffering and what we want to do is
kind of treat it as a rollercoaster
so like without wanting to kind of like
you know soften it too much we started
into implementing different things like
satanic involvement in Seban like moral
cultish elements that we could create
that theme-park ride
we're looking forward very much to VHS 2
but we're also looking forward to the
raid - now I know you're ramping up the
action for that what can we kind of
expect it's a little taste of what it'll
be yeah well we got we've got like a lot
of different characters this time we've
got a lot of different action sequences
it's very different from the first one
just not obviously set in one building
this time but we actually expand the
world out so there's a lot more location
work that we did this time and also we
finally got to incorporate some car
chases so so yeah that's that's been
quite fun actually stressful as hell to
shoot but but it's been fun it's been a
good challenge when we talked to you
last year Gareth at Kapow you told us
all about the step man's injury and that
famous flip over the balcony scene so
what's the bone-crunching a thing that's
happened during the raid to shoot so far
we had we had we had one we just
finished tuned like pickup days and last
weekend we had one one stunt guy who
tracked his head in the floor when he
fell off a car but he was okay he got
like maybe like five six cuts in the
back we said but thankfully no
concussion I'll have to check the
playback to see if there's anything else
that happened that was worse but so far
that's the most fresh memory in my mind
but he's okay now he came back to set
after he went to the hospital with a
nice big bandage around his head and
then he picked up his bag going home now
we live you of course your action what
would you say if they came knocking
maybe for Marvel to ask you to make an
action-packed superhero movie it's tough
for meanest difficult is the thing is
like right now where I am the the kind
of things that I'm doing I don't know if
I fit yet the superhero mold yet because
I I don't know it it's something I need
to learn at some point but I don't know
if I can deliver a pg-13 movie I don't
know how to do that yet I should learn
but yeah I'm not sure maybe a darker
superhero model it's Thunder goodness an
English language maybe maybe next
hopefully I'm gonna produce something
for Timo to direct in Indonesia first
and then after that I'm gonna look to do
something in u.s. maybe or somewhere
here maybe in UK what kind of genre
watch genre
for most like the action I guess but I
can
no surprise there but like you I
wouldn't put past like the idea of maybe
doing like I'd love to do a West and at
some point or musical or something yeah
yeah you never know right musical
Western nagging to yeah we'd like to say
that guys it's been lovely talking to
you guys
you